hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 12 video so much
stuff happened it was like arrow three
o'clock high if you've ever seen that
classic 80s movie big fight with the
bully after school we're still kind of
in the middle of the canary trilogy
that'll conclude next week with episode
13 aptly named Canaries but Stephen
Amell started a hashtag today called the
Emerald Archer Rises so I think that's
what the next arc of the show is gonna
be this last arc has told the story of
the rise of the new Black Canary
the next art might deal with Oliver's
evolution as green arrow so just careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet starting with top
five moments number five katana helps
Oliver get back to Starling as bummed as
I was the katana didn't come all the way
back with him that doesn't mean that we
won't see her again nothing's confirmed
or anything like that
but just don't don't count her out for
the rest of the season there were a
bunch of characters we saw in this
episode that were really small but they
were comic book characters I'm crossing
my fingers that they all come back
katana being at the top of that list
because she is badass with a sword I
like the way Oliver talked about that
too Rachele goal he's pretty good with a
sword good enough to jam one through
your chest given what we saw in the
episode you know what that means now he
has the sword that was used to pierce
him he's gonna have to learn how to use
it now and that's gonna be Merlyn
that'll train him I'm hoping I'm really
hoping the katana comes back to help him
with his you know Jedi sword training -
that's his lightsaber I know Stephen
Amell has his lightsaber Saturdays
that's as close as he's gonna get to
wielding a lightsaber is that racial
Ghul sword
make as many jokes about that as you
want once he and Merlyn start fighting
with those swords once they start
training that's all you're gonna see on
tumblr is just Stephen Amell lightsaber
gifs it's gonna be hilarious just roll
with it just roll with it visually that
like the scene of Oliver making his way
back into the city
it was very Batman Begins esque the
producers have always been really clear
about the way they take cues from
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
so anytime you see a scene that seems
like one of the Batman movies one of
Christopher Nolan's Batman movies it's
play an intentional reference Christian
Bale's Batman comes back to Gotham
returns from the dead Oliver comes back
to Starling returns from the dead as
much as Stephen Amell was hashtagging
the Emerald Archer Rises Batman Begins
could have been the subtitle for the
episode I saw a lot of you guys tweeting
at me about Dark Knight Rises about the
big battle royale between Batman and
Payne there was that in this episode
that big collides Battle of big Battle
Royale
it's actually taken from a Batman comic
book called no man's land I talked about
it a little bit in last week's arrow
video that's the basis for Dark Knight
Rises but if you want to go to the
source just call it arrow no man's land
it's actually a really great comic so if
you haven't read it you should check it
out moving on to number four T Merlin
slowly merges with team arrow as much as
Diggle said no to Merlin Oliver said yes
so we're getting like a backdoor merging
of Merlin and team arrow it's not like
they're gonna be buddy-buddy or anything
like that but even as far back as season
two the minute Merlin came back and we
knew he was alive he didn't die in
season one I had wanted him to team up
with Oliver but grudgingly there's no
way Oliver is ever gonna like him
there's there's too much bad blood
there's too much history between them
the thing they have in common is Thea
they both love Thea and they're all
about protecting family so Merlyn is
still gonna be Merlyn all we're still
gonna be Oliver but they will train
together the enemy of my enemy is my
friend temporarily as much as Merlyn
isn't the villain right now I do I do
think he's gonna do something really
shady at the end of the season like like
in the season finale there's no way he's
ever gonna be white shiny night Merlyn
right now he's more of an antihero I
love the way Felicity came down on this
too she's like hell no not having it
this is bullcrap when she said I don't
want to be someone you love what she
meant is she doesn't want Oliver to go
down the same path as Merlyn it's just
in doing so like the Oliver that she
knows would be gone the Oliver that
loves her would stop existing so she
would be a person he loved as in past
tense then you have to remember what
katana said earlier in the episode in
order to defeat racial goal Oliver has
to be willing to give up or forget the
thing that he loves most on the surface
that seems like Felicity I think it's a
little more complicated than that
in this next arc is gonna spell out what
that is so you can kind of see the
structure of the back half of the season
coming into scope you have the rise of
the canary over the you know first three
episodes of the back half then you have
a block of episodes
that's the rise of the Emerald Archer
Oliver training montage then you have
the finale the grand finale
Oliver verse racial goal moving on to
number three Battle Royale in the glades
so this is a lot of fun it is a huge
crowd scene so just from a technical
perspective
it was really amazing arrow has great
stunts so I knew it was gonna be a lot
of fun and they kind of ruined it in all
the promos like that zipline scene with
Oliver zipping away at the end that was
in the promo last week but we got to see
Wildcat and sin again I don't know if
they're coming back before the season
finale I'm hoping they do but it's not
confirmed and Wildcat the actor that
plays Wildcat has been cast on another
series when I saw him I was actually
really surprised but I guess that he got
cast on the other show after they filmed
this episode I will say I was a little
bummed that he went down so easy when he
went up against brick Wildcat in the
comics actually trained most of the
Justice League had a fight in hand hand
combat that's okay though this is arrows
version of Wildcat and being because
they're ply not gonna be able to use the
character a whole lot in other episodes
they wanted a plausible reason as to why
he wasn't hanging out with him all the
time so he just got his face punched up
real nice so he's gonna be recovering
from that once you're in the area
universe you're in for good so he could
still come back in a future season I was
so happy to see Beck's back though if
you wonder why sin hasn't been back more
often she was cast on MTV's screen TV
show they're doing a show based on the
screen movie series she was actually
really important to the episode too
she's gonna be the catalyst for Quentin
probably figuring out that Laurel is the
Black Canary you guys can let me know if
you agree but I think the only reason
that Quentin hasn't figured out that
Oliver is the arrow is because he
doesn't want to know his daughter Sara
in the canary that's a whole other story
so more people will probably learn what
laurels been up to and Marc Guggenheim
also teased that more people would learn
Oliver zayed entity I think that's gonna
be Thea if you're wondering what's
happening to break now obviously he's
gonna get sent to iron Heights I don't
know that we've seen the last of him
because he is like the brother blood of
the season like the person right below
the biggest villain of all racial Ghul
but vertigo is gonna be back in the next
episode so brick might just go away for
a couple episodes he might just be
chilling out in prison for the next
couple weeks moving on to number two
Batman Begins Merlyn edition I can't
remember the last time I mentioned it
but the producers said whenever they
were they were creating their version of
the Malcolm Merlyn character they
envisioned him as an evil Bruce Wayne
just like Bruce Wayne he goes to Nanda
Parbat to learn to harness his anger and
his fear the wig was kind of weird all
the acting amazing 100% totally on his
a-game my
though was tiny Nyssa giving him the
nickname magician that's a big departure
from the comics in the comics he was
named magician just because of his
showmanship I'm totally fine with him
changing it
arrows version is way better the funeral
scene with Minnie Tommy and Minnie
Oliver that was also a close second -
that was also a lot of fun the real
point of departure between the Bruce
Wayne character in the Malcolm Merlyn
character though is that moment in
Batman Begins when Rachael Ghul says
kill this thief he deserves to die for
stealing and Bruce Wayne's like I can't
do it I'm not a murderer they said that
in arrows version of the timeline
Malcolm Merlyn probably did kill that
thief John Barrowman has been really
open about where he sees his Myrtle and
character going he thinks he's on this
Redemption arc that he's just never
gonna get to like his life's journey is
all about Redemption and he's just never
gonna get there that's what all these
family stuff is all about especially
that last scene between Oliver Merlyn
and Thea Merlyn is just like the evil
old uncle that invites himself to all
the family parties
I feel like Oliver kind of saved Merlyn
in this episode had he killed brick I
think it would have been the end of his
relationship with Thea she would have
found out eventually and that would have
been it but now that he didn't kill her
they're that much closer he's like oh
thank you you did this for me Berlin's
like no I did it for me like he's slowly
healing that wound inside although it's
a hole that's never gonna be filled
that's what drama is all about something
is gonna push him over the edge again
and he'll go back to being the same old
Merlyn one of the big goals every season
is to take the group of characters shake
them up a whole bunch and then by the
end of the season get them back to
baseline Merlyn starts out the season
being a little sinister goes through
this big crucible finds a little bit of
redemption new relationship with his
daughter by the end of the season why
gonna be back to the same old tricks in
my number one moment Oliver tells Merlyn
in no uncertain terms that he will be
training him to fight ratio goal only
the student can defeat the master so
that actually works on a number of
levels
the minute katana said that for the
first time she was the first person to
say it in the episode they cut to a
scene of Merlyn and Thea so I feel like
that means Thea is gonna end up fighting
Merlyn by the end of the season
Oliver is gonna be Merlin's student he's
plugin to end up having to fight Merlyn
by the end of the season - Merlyn was
racial ghouls student so he'll probably
end up fighting British al Ghul it gets
really funny when you think about it at
trackway who's the student who's the
master so only the student can defeat
the master so who's gonna be defeating
who this season one of the best Easter
eggs in the episode though was when
Oliver walked into Thea's apartment and
said sorry I've been away I ran into an
old friend in Bludhaven and things got a
little crazy that's probably as close as
you'll get Nightwing appearance
Nightwing is gonna be on the Titans show
I don't think there's gonna be any
direct crossover between those so we're
probably not gonna see Nightwing on
arrow anytime soon but they can mention
Bludhaven as many times as they want
so everybody queue up the malcolm merlyn
Oliver Queen training montage
all I could picture after the episode
was like that Apollo Creed rocky scene
when they were running on the beach
together I'm just gonna wait for that
Stephen Amell Facebook video where he
puts a giant pair of tube socks and a
headband on here's my big question for
you guys let me know what your favorite
moment from the episode was but if the
student is the only one capable of
defeating the master does that mean that
regardless of whatever training Malcolm
gives to Oliver Malcolm is gonna be the
one to have to defeat ratio Ghul if
Stephen Amell is always posting pictures
of himself as Luke Skywalker
does that make Malcolm Merlyn Darth
Vader and we all remember how Return of
the Jedi went down so just think about
it that way
fun fact whenever they were initially
planning the Malcolm Merlyn character
they wanted Oliver Queen to be his
secret son but decided it was like way
to Star Wars Darth Vader it was too
on-the-nose
so they made Thea his secret daughter so
originally Oliver was supposed to be
Malcolm's son Italy at least in the
conception whenever they were first
conceiving the series it's just funny
how like no matter which TV show you go
to there's always gonna be something
that seems like Star Wars so I already
talked about most of the big Easter eggs
like the Batman no man's land storyline
there's actually some really cool
details though about the Ray Palmer atom
suit in the episode that we're gonna
first see that end so I'll explain that
the first time we're gonna see the suit
full on is gonna be episode 15 that
episode is called Nanda Parbat so
presumably we're going to visit Nanda
Parbat whether team arrow visits there
or we just get a lot of racial going
Nyssa scenes I know everyone's wondering
if Brandon Rath is gonna get his
shrinking powers if they're gonna get
Adam shrinking powers they haven't
confirmed yes or no originally the
answer was no but since they've opened
the door to superpowers on arrow I think
it's totally possible especially since
they're trying to develop a spin-off Ray
Palmer is actually going to guess star
in the flash
episode 18 the title that episode is
all-star team up so take that as you
will there's gonna be some tiny bees in
the episode so if there's gonna be like
thousands of tiny bees I feel like
that's just a prelude for Adam shrinkage
you guys can let me know what you think
about the Adam suit but I think it'll be
a little more interesting once we see it
running around on screen next week
though Caity Lotz guest starring some
red-hot canary on canary action thanks
in large part to wonderful vertigo
hallucinations I'll post that video
right after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get it
I'm also gonna be doing an arrow flash
Q&A this week after I post my agent
Carter video that's gonna be my next
video just in case you guys haven't seen
it yet I did a breakdown of the
daredevil Netflix trailer this morning
you can click here to watch that and the
trailer and you can click here for this
week's flash episode thank you so much
for watching so let's all high-five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you